Brace yourselves, Guardians of the
Galaxy fans! Director James Gunn
has a message that'll leave you
teary-eyed. His warning for the
third installment is cosmic - and
definitely worth a Groot or two.
After years of anticipation, director James
Gunn and Marvel Studios have finally released
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3." The Marvel
Cinematic Universe's cosmic group first debuted
in 2014, grossing over $333 million domestically,
emerging as one of the franchise's biggest hits.
The current iteration of Guardians
is getting the swan-song treatment,
with "Vol.3" set to be their last ride. What can
fans expect from this final installment? Well,
lots of tears, according to director James Gunn.
While speaking with Collider,
Gunn teased just how emotional
the final film in the trilogy would
be. He set our expectations saying,
"I know that there's been a lot of people
crying in the screening, so I guess people cry."
Scared your favorite Guardian is going
to bite the dust? Don't worry — not all
of "Vol. 3's" tears are the result
of sadness or grief. Gunn continued,
"But it's not all sad crying, there's
a lot of happy crying in the movie,
there's a lot of joy in the film. You
know, everybody talks about the emotion,
and it is emotional, but there's a lot of joy."
The film is packed with emotion, at least
according to Looper critic Audrey Fox,
who praised the threequel for
integrating a heartbreaking
backstory for Rocket Raccoon.
Fox wrote in their 7/10 review,
"It does right by all of the characters,
giving them the send-offs they deserve
— especially Rocket, who manages to
evoke more of an emotional response than
his little CGI face has any right to."
Seeing as the threequel serves as a heartfelt
goodbye to our favorite group of intergalactic
heroes, it more than makes sense that "Vol.
3" is the longest flick in the franchise.
The latest film in the MCU follows the
Guardians on a chaotic mission that sees
them racing against the clock to save one
of their own. "Vol. 3" notably features the
reunion of Star-Lord and Gamora, who last shared
the screen together in "Avengers: Endgame."
For fans, "Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 3" is more than just a satisfying
ending — it's a fitting and triumphant
send-off to some of Marvel's most quirky
and colorful characters. Audiences gave
the film the much coveted A CinemaScore,
all but proving Gunn's still got the charm
and spectacle he had with the first film.
"And we'll kill anyone who gets in our way."
"No, not kill anyone."
"Kill a few people."
"Kill no people."
"Kill one guy, one stupid guy who no one loves."
"Now you're just making it sad."
While Gunn and the rest of the crew are likely
basking in the film's positive reception, making
the film was no small task for the creative.
The director admitted to The Toronto Sun,
"I was on edge the whole time I was
making this movie. I knew how difficult
it was going to be to balance all of these
different characters and the final-ness of
their stories in this trilogy. So it
was always an uneasy feeling for me."
Gunn seems to have knocked it out of the park,
especially thanks to the film's extended
runtime. But how long exactly will audiences
get to spend with Star-Lord and the
rest of the gang this time around?
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" clocks in at
2 hours and 30 minutes, making it one of the
longest films in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
It's also the longest film in the trilogy,
with "Vol. 1" and "2" coming in at 2 hours
and 1 minute and 2 hours and 16 minutes,
respectively. It makes sense that
"Vol. 3" is the longest of the
bunch considering it wraps up the
arcs first set up in the 2014 film.
Prior to the film's release, Gunn made it clear
on Deadline's "Hero Nation" podcast that "Vol.
3" would be the last flick in the franchise to
feature this current roster of heroes. While
it remains to be seen what the future holds for
the next generation of films in the franchise,
it's all but likely that "Vol. 3" serves as
Gunn's final Marvel outing now that he's head
honcho at DC Studios. Audiences are clearly
excited to see Gunn wrap up his trilogy,
with the film earning $114 million over its
opening weekend at the domestic box office.